und wir warten nach wie vor auf die für
16 30 angekündigte pressekonferenz des
ministerpräsidenten von nordrhein
westfalen armin laschet die soll in
wenigen augenblicken beginnen in
düsseldorf in diesem saal und für die
nächsten 90 minuten ist auch eine ganze
reihe weiterer pressekonferenzen
angekündigt unter anderem die
pressekonferenz der bundeskanzlerin oder
ein statement für 17 uhr 30 bei all dem
können sie bei uns natürlich live dabei
sein
ein bisschen von dem was merkel und den
ministerpräsidenten beschlossen haben
ist schon nach außen gedrungen ich darf
ihnen da mal eine dpa-meldung vorlesen
bund und länder wollen eine art
kontaktverbot im kampf gegen die
ausbreitung des corona virus beschließen
kanzlerin angela merkel und die
ministerpräsidenten der länder einigten
sich nach informationen der deutschen
presse agentur am sonntag bei einer
telefonkonferenz die wie gesagt um 14
uhr stattgefunden hat darauf
ansammlungen von mehr als zwei personen
grundsätzlich zu verbieten
ausgenommen von diesem verbot dass ich
nicht mehr als zwei personen versammeln
dürfen ausgenommen von diesem verbot wer
sollen familien seien sowie personen die
miteinander im haushalt leben so weit
das erste was nach außen gedrungen ist
sobald die pressekonferenz in düsseldorf
beginnt schalten wir live hin
und jetzt begrüße ich in aachen
professor emanuel richter
politikwissenschaftler an der rwth in
aachen wieder schöne sonntag nach aachen
von dieser stelle
professor richter was haben wir denn zu
erwarten was die ministerpräsidenten und
angela merkel heute nachmittag
geschlossen haben
zunächst einmal wird es ja nicht weiter
zweiteres sein können als eine einigung
unter der unter den ministerpräsidenten
denn das sind natürlich alles föderale
autonome
entscheidungen die da getroffen werden
aber das wurde ja auch in der
öffentlichkeit kritisiert sie sollen
eben jetzt koordiniert verlaufen und
deshalb eben auch die einschaltung der
bundesregierung das heißt die
bundesregierung hat an der stelle
eigentlich kein richtiges eigen recht
sondern kann eben nur versuchen zu
koordinieren und dann natürlich in einem
extremfall hat sie in der tat
eingriffsrechte das ist aber eigentlich
der verteidigungsfall der dann im
grundgesetz geregelt ist also insofern
versucht man jetzt mehr als es in der
vergangenheit geschehen ist zu
koordinieren unter den autonomen
länderchefs und wenn man so will
eigentlich auch unter den autonomen
kommunen und unteren regionalen ebenen
den katastrophenschutz wie auch
gesundheitsschutz sind eigentlich die
zentral organisiert ja dann lassen sie
mich dann mal nachhaken
wir müssen das vertagen denn ich bekomme
gerade die nachricht dass der
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen laschet in
düsseldorf eingetroffen ist
die pressung des landeskabinetts das
thema ist die aktuelle lage und die
weiteren maßnahmen maßnahmen der
landesregierung zur eindämmung der
korona virus pandemie herr
ministerpräsident sie haben das wort ja
vielen dank bevor ich zu den ergebnissen
der heutigen kabinettssitzung und der
bund länder gespräche ausführen möchte
ich danke sagen
in diesen schweren zeiten erleben wir
tagtäglich zeichen der solidarität und
des miteinanders der hilfsbereitschaft
die gewürdigt werden sollten auch weil
sie mut machen und unabhängig von denen
die in diesen minuten überall ihren
dienst leisten insbesondere in den
krankenhäusern gibt es viele
bürgerschaftliche initiativen die
älteren menschen bei den einkäufen
helfen die ältere menschen die in den
wohnungen bleiben nicht alleine lassen
und alle denen möchte ich danke sagen
möchte danke sagen den kranken
einrichtungen den pflegeeinrichtungen
den lebensmittelgeschäften die ja auch
am sonntag geöffnet haben können den
drogerien und apotheken den arztpraxen
der polizei und der feuerwehr
viele arbeiten bis zur erschöpfung
werden dass auch in den nächsten tagen
noch tun und dafür der dank des gesamten
landes mein dank gilt auch all den
bürgern und wenn man heute auf die
straßen geht kann man es schon
feststellen die sich an die regeln
halten die kontakte vermeiden unnötige
kontakte das sind die allermeisten
bürger im ganzen land und denen gilt ein
dank sie haben den ernst der lage
erkannt
erst es gilt jetzt alle verfügbaren
ressourcen zu mobilisieren und daran
arbeiten wir als landesregierung auf
allen ebenen wir beschleunigen prozesse
und reduzieren bürokratie wo es nur geht
krankenkassen krankenhausgesellschaft
und der medizinische dienst haben sich
mit bundeswehr mit
landesgesundheitsminister laumann darauf
verständigt vorübergehend
verwaltungsaufgaben zurückzustellen wir
haben finanzielle einigungen erzielt
damit die versorgung der erkrankten
menschen nicht an bürokratie scheitert
wir haben in den letzten tagen die
bundeswehr um hilfe gebeten für die
versorgung mit schutz materialien
insbesondere im kreis heinsberg
soldatinnen und soldaten der bundeswehr
haben am heutigen morgen damit begonnen
dem kreis heinsberg schutz materialien
zu übergeben und zwei beatmungsgeräte
für intensivstationen zur verfügung zu
stellen
wir liefern schutz material mit hilfe
des deutschen roten kreuzes aus an
krankenhäusern die lkws sind unterwegs
seit der nacht und werden heute den
ganzen tag weiter krankenhäuser
beliefern wir mobilisieren das personal
für die kritische infrastruktur denn wir
wollen notbetreuung an schulen und
kindertageseinrichtungen auf mehr
berufstätige ausweiten sowie auch für
das wochenende
insbesondere für das vor uns liegende
osterwochenende und die osterferien
ausweiten
wir mobilisieren personal für die
gesundheitsämter auch das war ein
wichtiges thema heute in der
kabinettssitzung dass wir den kommunen
vor ort auch als land mit personal jetzt
helfen wir wollen den einsatz von
bediensteten der landesregierung in
ihrer nachgeordneten behörden zur
unterstützung der gesundheitsämter
ermöglichen und organisieren und dabei
geht es um kontaktpersonen management um
regionales krisen management um die
erfassung und übertragung von
patientendaten und die besetzung von
hotlines denn viele viele hunderttausend
bürger greifen zurück auf die hotline
des landes auf die hotlines vor ort und
da muss auch geschultes personal
bereitstehen dass diese hotlines
kompetenz bei die kompetent bedient zum
krisen management in diesen tagen gehört
aber auch in ganz besonderer weise dass
wir unsere wirtschaft dh unternehmen
selbstständige arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer vor dem kollaps bewahren
wir müssen auch jetzt schon an den
zeitpunkt nach der krise denken und
alles tun damit unsere gesamte
wirtschaft damit unsere
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer nach
der krise wieder arbeiten können und
deshalb haben wir in der
kabinettssitzung heute den
nachtragshaushalt beschlossen der nrw
rettungsschirm stellt 25 milliarden euro
bereit in einem sondervermögen das ist
das größte hilfs programm das das land
nordrhein westfalen seit bestehen des
landes seit 1946 beschlossen hat wir
stellen alle erforderlichen gelder in
der krise schnell bereit unbürokratisch
bereit und wirksam bereit wir wollen das
ein gesundes unternehmen wegen des
wirtschaftlichen einbruchs an mangelnder
liquidität scheitert aber bereits am
donnerstag gesagt dass eine krise
unbekannten ausmaßes auch hilfe in
bisher nie gekannter größenordnung
verlangt das bedeutet dass wir die
mittel die jetzt bereit stellen auch
ganz schnell in unternehmen zugute
kommen lassen müssen wir sind am ende
des monats gehälter müssen ausgezahlt
werden so dass in den nächsten tagen
diese maßnahmen wirken
wir haben das in nordrhein-westfalen
parteiübergreifend geplant das was in
der nächsten woche geschieht im landtag
wird getragen auch von den drei
oppositionsfraktionen und deshalb gilt
auch hier mein dank dass in der krise
jenseits aller politischen unterschiede
alle zusammenstehen und alles zusammen
schnell handeln und deshalb hat am
freitag die landesregierung gemäß
artikel 38 der landesverfassung eine
sondersitzung des landtags beantragt
heute kam der kabinettsbeschluss die
unterlagen dieses haushaltsgesetzes sind
heute noch den fraktionen zugegangen
damit sie sich sachgerecht damit
beschäftigen können dann wird es am
dienstag eine sondersitzung des
landtages geben mit einer unterrichtung
wo ich die öffentlichkeit über alle
maßnahmen nur einmal informieren werde
dann gibt es die erste lesung dann die
fachausschüsse und noch am gleichen tag
die zweite und dritte lesung und die
verkündigung der gesetze das hieße vom
wirtschafts gipfel bis zum inkrafttreten
der gesetze ist nicht mal eine woche
vergangen
allen die daran mitgewirkt haben und ein
solches gesetz braucht auch viel
präzision in der ausarbeitung gilt mein
dank am heutigen tag das bundeskabinett
seinerseits wird am montag eingesetzt
paket zur bekämpfung des corona virus
verabschieden
auch dieses am mittwoch dann in erster
und zweiter dritter lesung im bundestag
und am freitag in einer sondersitzung
des bundesrates so dass auch hier alle
fristen außer kraft gesetzt sind und
alle verfassungsorgane gemeinschaftlich
handeln
dieses gesetz dieses paket enthält das
krankenhaus entlastungsgesetz es erhält
es enthält regelungen zum ausgleich des
verdienstausfalls bei betreuung von
kindern aufgrund von schul und kita
schließungen es gibt ein gesetz zur
anpassung des insolvenzrechtes das heißt
dass jetzt jemand der in
zahlungsunfähigkeit ist nicht so schnell
insolvenz anmelden muss und es gibt
unterbrechungsfrei strafgerichtliche
hauptverhandlungen es gibt ein sozial
schutzpaket es gibt ein gesetz zum
schutz der bevölkerung bei einer
epidemischen lage von nationaler
bedeutung es kommt das kurzarbeitergeld
es kommt der nachtragshaushalt und es
kommt ein wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds gesetz zu allen
diesen bestandteilen liefen und laufen
auch jetzt noch die abstimmungen
zwischen bund und ländern
der föderalismus ist handlungsfähig
wir haben in den letzten tagen schon
viele maßnahmen beschlossen
als erstes bundesland neben
schleswig-holstein hat nordrhein
westfalen am vergangenen sonntag das ist
erst eine woche her
das öffentliche leben massiv
heruntergefahren und am montag haben wir
uns dann mit allen ländern bundesweit
darauf verständigt
zuvor haben wir mit einigen wenigen
ländern veranstaltungen massiv
eingeschränkt das ist für jeden sichtbar
am einstellen des spielbetriebs und der
zuschauer spiele der fußball bundesliga
das betrifft aber auch viele andere
veranstaltungen
einer größenordnung unter 1000 personen
das ziel war und ist dabei immer soziale
kontakte herunterfahren das
ansteckungsrisiko deutlich minimieren
und die menschen folgen dem sie halten
abstand sie folgen den weisungen der
ordnungsbehörden und dafür danke ich
und während die mehrheit der bürgerinnen
und bürger erkannt hat dass es um leben
oder tod geht beobachten wir immer noch
viel unvernunft
es gibt immer noch menschen die regeln
und empfehlungen missachten und sich so
maximal unsolidarisch ja gefährlich
verhalten und es gibt menschen die mich
wütend machen wenn ich von corona partys
und anderen massenansammlungen lese das
dulden wir nicht mehr
wir stehen in nordrhein-westfalen
solidarisch wir gehen jetzt konsequent
gegen alle die vor die regelbrecher sind
das prinzip null toleranz gegen
rechtsbruch wird jetzt auf den
öffentlichen plätzen für die wenigen die
sich nicht an die regeln halten
durchgesetzt
und um alle menschen zur vernunft zu
bringen braucht es aus meiner sicht
weitere strengere maßnahmen und ein
gemeinsames geschlossenes vorgehen von
bund und ländern vertrauen erhält der
staat vor allem wenn er geschlossen
vorgeht die einheit der länder mit dem
bund ist ein hohes gut gerade in der
krise und die menschen müssen notwendige
regeln zum schutz von gesundheit und
leben nachvollziehen können
viele fordern deshalb jetzt eine
ausgangssperre
nach unserer einschätzung ist nicht das
verlassen der wohnung die gefahr
die gefahr ist der enge unmittelbare
soziale kontakt und deshalb halte ich
ein kontaktverbot
ab zwei personen für das geeignete
mittel
meine überzeugung kontakt verboten sind
im vergleich zu einer ausgangssperre für
die unterbrechung von infektionsketten
verhältnismäßiger zielgerichteter und
besser zu vollziehen denn alles was wir
beschließen muss auch vollzogen werden
damit die bürger erkennen der staat
setzt recht aber es wird auch überall
durchgesetzt
und ich bin froh dass wir als länder mit
dem bund einig sind durch ein
kontaktverbot infektionskette zu
unterbrechen und ansteckungen zu
verlangsamen
zentral dabei ist der gedanke soziale
kontakte über die kernfamilie hinaus
einzustellen
insbesondere im öffentlichen raum aber
natürlich auch im privaten raum
die wichtigsten punkte sind
zusammenkünfte und ansammlungen in der
öffentlichkeit von mehr als zwei
personen sind verboten
ausnahmen gelten für kern familien für
lebenspartner für zwingende
geschäftliche berufliche oder
dienstliche gründe für den öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und bei beerdigungen
diese verbote werden durchgesetzt
durch die örtlichen ordnungsämter und
die polizei des landes
wir werden unverzüglich alle restaurants
und gaststätten schließen
es wird untersagt alle nicht dringend
notwendigen dienstleistungen bei denen
der abstand der mindestabstand von
mensch zu mensch nicht mehr da ist zum
beispiel bei friseuren zum beispiel bei
massagesalon es zum beispiel bei tattoo
studios und anderen dienstleistungen wo
menschen ganz eng aufeinander treffen
diese maßnahmen haben wir nordrhein
westfalen heute mittag im kabinett
beraten und als
beschlossen die entsprechende
rechtsverordnung und das ist ein
instrument das wir jetzt nutzen das land
erlässt eine rechtsverordnung die
verbindlich ist die rechtsverordnung des
gesundheitsministers wird noch heute
erlassen und gilt wie alle anderen
maßnahmen bis zum 19 april also bis zum
ende der osterferien innenminister und
kommunalministerin werden die einhaltung
mittels ordnungsdiensten und polizei
überwachen und ich sage dazu
verstöße werden wir hart verfolgen durch
empfindliche bußgelder bis zu 25.000
euro bei leichten und strafrechtliche
verfolgung bei schweren verstößen
wir haben im kampf gegen das virus keine
zeit zu verlieren
es braucht besonnenes aber auch
entschlossenes handeln das virus muss
bekämpft werden jetzt sofort mit allen
mitteln die zum erfolg führen
die berichte und bilder aus ländern wie
italien müssen uns eine lehre sein
wir brauchen also wirksame
entscheidungen damit sie wirksam sind
müssen sie auch durchsetzbar sein
wir dürfen nicht die vernünftigen
überwachen sollen wir müssen die
unvernünftigen bestrafen hart und klar
die heute von bund und ländern auch auf
unsere initiative hin beschlossenen
maßnahmen sind dafür in besonderem maße
geeignet
herzlichen dank der ministerpräsident
jetzt haben die gelegenheit für ein paar
nachfragen frau hülsmeier
ausgeschaltet der kanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten verlautete dass sie
mit dem bayerischen ministerpräsidenten
in einen streit oder ähnliches geraten
sein sollen wegen der tatsache dass herr
söder ja vorgeprescht ist bei vielen
maßnahmen und sie haben jetzt ja auch
gerade erklärt warum sie eine des
kontakt verbot für sinnvoll halten als
ausgangssperren können sie sagen was was
da in der schalte das was da los war
sind sie mit herrn söder
aneinandergeraten und kritisieren sie
das vorgehen bayern also ich berichte
nicht aus internen schalten der
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundeskanzlerin bayern und das saarland
sind einen weg gegangen das respektieren
wir
verständigt haben sich alle länder das
kontaktverbot zu unterbinden sind
darum freuen wir uns nun erfolge noch
also alle nennen da geht es zurück auf
einen vorschlag von nordrhein westfalen
dieses kontaktverbot haben sie da die
vorlage gemacht wir haben zusammen
gearbeitet und einige länder sind diesem
weg folgt aber ich finde es ist
respektabel es ist eine frage der
herangehensweise der eine weg ist die
ausgangssperre mit vielen vielen
ausnahmen oder andere weg ist den
kontakt zu bestrafen und unser ansatz
ist nicht dass die wohnung verlassen es
ist wichtig dass menschen die wohnung
verlassen dass sie an die frische luft
gehen
auch das ist eine gesundheitspolitische
maßnahmen
das entscheidende ist kontakte mit
anderen erst recht in gruppen erst recht
gemeinsame größere begegnungen das muss
jetzt verhindert werden und dem sind
viele länder die überwiegende zahl
gefolgt werden sie sich meldet ja dazu
der präzisierung herr minister laschet
habe ich das richtig verstanden dass das
was sie jetzt für nordrhein-westfalen
vorgeschlagen haben dass das im prinzip
jetzt bundesweit von den meisten ländern
so umgesetzt
sollten das auch innerhalb der länder
eine möglichst einheitliche regelungen
gelten soll
das ziel war es immer mein ziel war dass
bund und länder gemeinsam agieren
das ist heute erreicht worden mit
unterschiedlichen akzenten die in jedem
land noch einmal den regionalen
besonderheiten entsprechend
ausformuliert werden in wenn sie
unmittelbar an der grenze liegen wir das
saarland haben sie eine andere
fragestellungen zu beantworten als ein
land das kann die grenznähe hat aber der
große konsens ist das kontaktverbot das
jetzt auch durchgesetzt wird
da die fragen die ihr per e mail
eingegangen sind die drehen sich erlaube
mir das wesentliche komplex der gerade
gestellt wurde wenn nicht sofort
aufschreiben wenn die nachfrage ist in
zwei nachfragen haben dann doch jetzt
stelle ich eine frage von den
schwerdtfeger der sich um das thema
wirtschaft drehte themenkomplex von
rheinischen post christian schwerdtfeger
meine frage lautet der ministerpräsident
der einzelhandel restaurants unternehmen
et cetera leiden unter enormen
finanziellen einbußen könnte man
unternehmen und einzelhändler und so
weiter nicht von der zahlung von
jeglicher form von steuern befreien
beziehungsweise dieser aussetzen um sie
der korona krise finanziell und
unbürokratisch zu entlasten
das ist in unserem paket das
landeskabinett heute beschlossen hat
enthalten
wir haben steuerstundungen wir haben
eine besondere regelung zur umsatzsteuer
wir haben alles was an entlastungen
möglich ist insbesondere ob bei
vorauszahlungen die ja gerade in diesen
tagen fällig werden so geregelt dass
nicht an steuern ein unternehmen am ende
in die insolvenz gehen muss sondern
diese entlastungen sind im beschluss des
landeskabinetts den in der nächsten
woche auch der landtag dann beraten wird
enthalte ok also ich nehme jetzt hier
mal dass die fragen von den schmalen er
blasius in der berger beantwortet sein
sollte nämlich jetzt mal auch eine frage
von dem magazin report kh die sich an
das gesundheitsministerium richtig da
gibt es auch hin leiten von dieser
stelle wenn hier keine frage wir sind
dann danken wir für kommen falls mal
noch
ich habe noch eine frage zu den kontakt
verboten wie wir das denn konkret
ausgestaltet jetzt für büros und für
werkhallen also es wird ja vielleicht
noch produktionen die in die jetzt noch
laufen gibt es da ausnahmen wie die wir
das gemacht nein das gilt nicht für das
arbeitsleben da muss jedes unternehmen
das sind ja sehr unterschiedliche
anforderungen selbst darauf achten wie
können wir möglichst infektions
übertragungen verhindern das kann man
nicht in einer landesverordnung regeln
das arbeitsleben ist aus gegriffen
wir gehen den umgekehrten weg wir
schließen insbesondere die
dienstleistungen wo es einen kontakt
gibt zwischen dem bürger und dem
dienstleister also beispiel friseure
das wird generell geschlossen da wo noch
produziert wird ist der appell an die
unternehmen abstände so weit wie möglich
einzuhalten und schutzmaßnahmen im
unternehmen zu treffen
okay die rechtsverordnung die
angesprochen wurde werden wir dann nach
ergehen heute auch veröffentlichen
herzlichen dank für kommen sondern noch
ein ja soweit also die pressekonferenz
des ministerpräsidenten von nordrhein
westfalen armin laschet es ist ja
wichtig das was laschet soeben verkündet
hat das sind die maßnahmen für nordrhein
westfalen im prinzip sollen die
bundesweit sehr sehr ähnlich sein
insbesondere das zentrale element das
kontaktverbot von gruppen über zwei
personen das soll bundesweit gelten wir
hören auch aus einigen ländern zb
sachsen dass das dort schon erlassen
worden ist aber viele viele details sind
unterschiedlich deswegen werden wir ihn
jetzt den den nächsten minuten weitere
pressekonferenzen von
ministerpräsidenten übertragen als
nächstes folgt der ministerpräsident von
baden württemberg winfried kretschmann
hier sehen sie schon das bild aus
stuttgart vorliegen
und bis das los geht haben wir ganz kurz
die gelegenheit das einzuordnen was wir
soeben gehört haben von armin laschet
einzuordnen zusammen mit professor
emanuel richter politikwissenschaftler
universität aachen zugeschaut
die jetzt aus berlin herr richter der
kern dessen was bekannt gegeben wurde
keine ausgangssperre
aber eine kontakt begrenzung auf zwei
personen
lassen sie uns das analysieren was genau
wurde da beschlossen
naja das ist in der tat sozusagen die
umgekehrte kontaktsperre dass das
umgekehrte ausgangsverbot gewissermaßen
in dem man sagt man will das was die
folgen von verbreitung bedeutet nämlich
dass eben mehrere personen beieinander
stehen und dann infektionszahlen
vervielfachen dass man das unterbindet
also es ist im grunde schon so eine art
von ausgangssperre denn man kann sich
schlecht vorstellen dass man das ein
held ohne dass man sich jetzt weiterhin
im öffentlichen raum bewegt man muss
sich irgendwie nach hause zurück ziehen
aber es ist club formuliert und ich fand
auch interessant dass eben jetzt nicht
nur über die unmittelbaren reaktionen
gesprochen wurde also was man tun muss
im moment sondern dass man auch eben
sehr genau und sehr intensiv nachdenkt
über die langfristigen folgen sprich die
ökonomische entwicklung die zu
bewältigen ist mit einer reihe von neuen
gesetzgebungen die herrliche der
angekündigt hat trotzdem noch zu den
details dieses kontaktverbot professor
richter ich habe das schon so verstanden
es ist mehr nach wie vor und allen
anderen bürgern erlaubt nach draußen zu
gehen mit dem hund oder spazieren zu
gehen oder zu joggen aber ich muss
aufpassen dass ich da eben nicht in
kontakt komme mit anderen personen und
ich kann nach wie vor einkaufen gehen
und ich kann nach wie vor wenn ich nicht
im home-office bin zu meiner
arbeitsstelle gehen
aber stellen sie sich vor das einkaufen
ich habe das selbst eben jetzt auch
schon mehrfach erlebt wird ja vor diesem
hintergrund nicht einfacher also auch da
muss man ja bei diesen notwendigen
gängen die man zu tun und erledigen hat
muss man ja darauf achten dass man
abstände ein held dass man eben jetzt
auch an der kasse gibt gewissermaßen des
supermarktes keine ansammlung bildet
also das wird alles nicht so ganz
einfach sein aber es ist in der tat der
einzige richtige schritt in im moment um
eben zu sagen in die ausbreitung
findet nach wie vor exponentiell stadt
und das muss eben unterbunden und
eingedämmt werden und insofern reagiert
man auf diese weise mit eben dieser
kontakt mit diesem kontaktverbot
jetzt ist ja im vorfeld und in den
letzten tagen und wochen immer wieder
kritisiert worden dass in der
bundesrepublik deutschland nicht
einheitlich reagiert wird dass jedes
bundesland etwas anderes macht teilweise
preschen städte vor bayern söder immer
wieder vorgeprescht das was wir da jetzt
gehört haben ich habe das so verstanden
im prinzip haben sich da alle
bundesländer auf dieses verbot über zwei
personen geeinigt
ja wobei man immer wieder betonen muss
das ist ländersache also das wird in der
bevölkerung auch vielfach falsch
eingeschätzt der katastrophenschutz
gesundheitsschutz der infektionsschutz
ist eigentlich ländersache zum teil ja
sogar in der örtlichen hoheit ja was zum
beispiel katastrophenfall angeht also
insofern ist das zunächst einmal zu
betonen die länder haben da eine
autonomie
es macht auch an vielen stellen sinn
weil sie unterschiedlich betroffen sind
aber gleichwohl muss man natürlich
versuchen eben zwischen den wenigen
bundesländern die die bundesrepublik im
vergleich zu den anderen vertragsstaaten
dennoch da irgendeine art von einheit
herzustellen und das hat man ja
geschafft indem man tatsächlich jetzt
mit der heutigen konferenz und mit der
heutigen schallte es geschafft hat das
fast überall einheitliche regelungen
getroffen worden sind so dass man sagen
kann ja also da wirkt schon auch der
bund im hintergrund mit er koordiniert
er ermuntert so einigung und zur
vereinheitlichung und das ist glaube ich
mit diesen heutigen beschlüssen soweit
man das übersehen kann dann müsste man
noch mal abwarten was die anderen
ministerpräsidenten dazu sagen aber ich
glaube es ist mit diesem heutigen
beschlüssen gut gelungen würden sie denn
sagen dass in dieser krise der
föderalismus in deutschland gut
funktioniert oder ist das gegenteil der
fall hätte man von anfang an viel
vielmehr auf zentrale und gemeinsame
lösungen setzen müssen na ja man muss es
wenn ich sozusagen als fachwissen
sprechen darf muss man schon sagen der
föderalismus funktioniert gut und
föderale autonomie muss auch gewahrt
werden
deutschland hat in seiner geschichte mit
der auflösung und zentralisierung ganz
schlechte erfahrungen gemacht denken wir
an das zwanzigste jahrhundert
das ist natürlich im moment für manche
unbefriedigend weil man eben sie dass es
in der tat so angefangen hat das einige
vorgeprescht sind andere länder gar
nichts gemacht haben oder weniger
gemacht haben und die bevölkerung nicht
verstanden hat warum man das so macht
und was das bedeutet aber in der tat ein
funktionsfähiger föderalismus hat die
autonomie der länder zu wahren sollte
aber natürlich in so einem
bedrohungsfall versuchen zu koordinieren
und wie gesagt das hat jetzt na ja
vielleicht wenn man es breit sieht
ungefähr 14 tage gedauert bis man sich
da gut zusammengefunden und
zusammengerauft hat jetzt hat man es
aber erreicht und ich glaube auf dem
niveau kann man leider arbeiten ohne
jetzt den deutschen föderalismus zu
beschädigen
derjenige der immer wieder vorgeprescht
ist ist der bayerische ministerpräsident
sie da er hat halt er hat als erster
gesagt wir schließen die schulen er hat
als erster am freitag alle anderen unter
druck gesetzt und hat gesagt wir machen
wir gehen jetzt in richtung
ausgangssperre ist das eine stärke des
föderalismus eine stärke der bayerischen
regierung eine stärke von söder dass er
da einfach vorangegangen ist gesagt hat
wir müssen jetzt handeln und dann haben
wir die andere nachgezogen
oder ist es eine schwäche weil die
bürger nicht mehr wissen wo sie dran
sind das eine land macht so das andere
land macht so ist nicht so ganz einfach
zu verstehen da hat dann baden
württemberg gesagt nur drei personen
sind erlaubt in berlin hat man gesagt
nur zehn personen sind erlaubt jetzt
scheint sich auf zwei personen
bundesweit zu einigen na ja das muss man
den deutschen föderalismus einfach zu
gestehen ich will auch daran erinnern es
gibt ja auch örtliche regelungen es gibt
ja in einigen orten freiburg war jetzt
in den letzten stunden und tagen öffnet
im gespräch und ostbayerische orte es
gibt ja in einigen orten auch noch mal
sozusagen wirkliche ausgangssperren das
heißt also noch viel rigidere lösungen
zur bekämpfung der ausbreitung also
insofern ist das immer wieder ein stück
föderalismus der natürlich auf der
länder eben nicht aufhört sondern der
nach unten weiter geht kommunale
eigenständigkeit ja eigenständigkeit von
stadtregierungen und klar söder hat ja
das kennt man ja auch aus bayern an
vielen stellen so eine art alleingang
gemacht wurde ja dafür auch kritisiert
und übrigens auch von
ministerpräsidenten so ein bisschen
hinter vorgehaltener hand aber das war
schon deutlich zu vernehmen und
gleichzeitig hat er natürlich als erster
das durchgesetzt was jetzt heute
gewissermaßen für alle bundesländer gilt
das heißt er war so ein bisschen was wie
avantgarde wenn man das so nennen darf
und wenn man mal so die
beliebtheitswerte im moment sich
anschaut dann zeigt es ja die
bevölkerung hat das was söder da sehr
resolut aber irgendwie auch
aufklärerisch und erklärend durchgesetzt
hat hat das ja gutgeheissen
das heißt also man hat das geschätzt man
redet ja davon das wäre doch auch am
ende sogar ein kanzlerkandidat diese
kanzlerkandidatenfrage wird ja auch
immer wieder diskutiert also insofern
hat er sich da offenbar was die
öffentliche wirkung anbetrifft meriten
verdient und insofern war das ja ein
stück verbrechen aber eben auch ein
stück von der präsentation von lösungen
die die anderen dann übernommen haben
also insofern können muss man ihm das
zugutehalten dass hat er an der stelle
dann doch irgendwie gut gemacht
professor richter wir haben im lauf
dieses gesprächs er festgestellt sie
sind ein überzeugter föderalist und
glauben daran dass das die beste lösung
auch in so einem krisenfall ist trotzdem
im vorfeld dieser
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit merkel
ist auch spekuliert worden dass die
länderkompetenzen in der bekämpfung
dieser corona krise kompetenzen abgeben
würden an den bund damit es
bundeseinheitliche regelungen geben kann
wenn wir jetzt die pressekonferenz von
armin laschet analysierend davon war
überhaupt nicht die rede also ich
vermute mal da ist nichts in dieser
richtung beschlossen worden obwohl das
ja durch
aus gefordert wurde ja und obwohl es die
gesetzgebung ja gibt also das
infektionsschutzgesetz ist eine
bundeseinheitliche regelung das robert
koch institut ist eine bundeseinrichtung
also dem bundesgesundheitsministerium
untergeordnet es gibt natürlich bundes
regelungskompetenz an dieser stelle und
alles was bisher geschehen ist beruft
sich in der tat auf den auf das
infektionsschutzgesetz das in seinem
paragrafen 38 und 30 31 schon sehr
drastische maßnahmen vorsieht also
insofern ist es nicht so dass der bund
gar nicht in erscheinung treten kann
oder muss und sollten sondern er tut es
ja und ich denke das was jetzt lasse zb
verkündet hat sind ja rechtsverordnungen
die jedes land für sich einfach aus
rechtlichen gründen
beschließen muss weil das grundgesetz an
dieser stelle eigentlich bis auf
gewissermaßen die kriegerische bedrohung
gar keinen fall vorsieht wo der bund
automatisch die gesamtkompetenz und die
zentrale kompetenz hat solche maßnahmen
durchzusetzen also man muss sich da
immer versuchen auch im rahmen der
vorstellung unserer rechtsordnung zu
bewegen und die sagt eben es nur im
äußersten notfall der eigentlich für den
kriegsfall vorgesehen ist tritt der bund
unmittelbar in erscheinungen kann zum
beispiel dann auch polizeibehörden
koordinieren und ähnliches zentrales
einsetzen aber ansonsten müssen dass die
länder für sich entscheiden und klar
wenn man es dann koordiniert dann hat
man ja auch ein stück bundes
einheitlichkeit gewagt also insofern
glaube ich ist das jetzt kein problem
was irgendwie uns auch
verfassungsrechtliches kopfzerbrechen
bereiten muss oder was jetzt irgendwie
an den rand der verfassungsgemäßheit der
verfassungsmäßigkeit heranreicht sondern
was eben die ausschöpfung unserer
grundstruktur mit ihrer mit ihrem
starken föderalen gewicht was diese
eigentlich bestärkt an dieser stelle ja
dann also vielen dank für diese
einschätzung dessen was sich da im
spannungsfeld zwischen zentralstaat
föderalismus und kompetenzen der
kommunen bei uns tut vielleicht ein
letzter blick noch auf das was armin
laschet
verkündet hat die stützung der
wirtschaft die stützung der
gesundheitsämter ist ihnen da eine
maßnahme aufgefallen die besonders
erwähnenswert wäre ja ich fand das
einfach gut dass er nach vorne blickt
weil in der tat ich meine wir haben
natürlich im moment eine akute not
nämlich die bekämpfung der ausbreitung
aber wir haben auch eine langfristige
not nenne ich die das auffangen der
wirtschaftlichen folgen
und da hat er mit dem ganzes dem ganzen
gesetzesbündel was er vorsieht glaube
ich der meister richter darf ich sie an
dieser stelle unterbrechen leider ganz
unhöflich aber ich sehe auf einer
monitor dass der ministerpräsident von
hessen volker bouffier zu seinem
statement bereit ist und wie gesagt
haben wir ausführlich erörtert die virus
bekämpfen ist ländersache
jetzt wollen wir zu hören wie reagiert
hessen in dieser krise volker bouffier
ministerpräsident von hessen
jetzt bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher ob
volker bouffier seine pressekonferenz
beginnen beginnen will oder ob er noch
auf ein zeichen wartet lust wird die
brille auf und wieder ab wir haben an
der stelle einfach ein bisschen geduld
sie sehen liebe zuschauer liebe
zuschauer folgten gradmann damen und
herren vor wenigen minuten ist die
telefonschaltkonferenz der kanzlerin mit
den ministerpräsidenten der länder zu
ende gegangen
der ministerpräsident volker bouffier
wird sich jetzt darüber informieren und
auch über die auswirkungen für hessen
bitte schön herr ministerpräsident ja
sagen sie herzlich gegrüßt meine damen
und herren wir haben gerade eine
gemeinsame konferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin und einer reihe von
bundesministerin und bundesministern und
den kollegen ministerpräsidenten und
minister plänen der länder gehabt und
sind zu darüber freue ich mich ganz
besonders zur gemeinsamen entscheidungen
gekommen
wir sehen dass wir eine sehr sehr ernste
lage haben darüber hab ich sie mehrfach
unterrichtet und trotzdem müssen wir
besonnen bleiben
wir haben am freitag einschneidende
maßnahmen beschlossen
ich erinnere daran die schließung der
gaststätte nicht erinnere daran dass für
die zahl beschränkt haben
wer sich im öffentlichen raum gemeinsam
bewegen kann und ich möchte mich
zunächst einmal herzlich bedanken dafür
dass viele bürgerinnen und bürger das
auch wirklich beherzigt haben die lage
in hessen war gestern so das haben alle
berichtet auch alle polizeipräsidien
dass die bürger sich in ganz großer zahl
danach gerichtet haben und das ist gut
so
wir können viele beschlüsse fassen aber
am ende müssen die menschen auch selbst
sich danach richten und deshalb
appelliere ich auch heute wieder daran
dass das was wir gemeinsam wollen
nämlich dass die zahl der kontakte nach
möglichkeit so weit reduziert wird wie
es irgend geht
dass das der entscheidende schritte die
schrecklichen bilder aus italien und zum
teil auch aus spanien mahnen uns es geht
hier darum dass wirklich alle mitmachen
und deshalb ist es gut dass wir in
deutschland und auch gemeinsam
entschieden haben bestimmte maßnahmen zu
beschließen und dazu darf ich ihnen
lagen
das meiste was heute vereinbart wurde
haben wir in hessen schon gemacht und es
gibt zwei punkte über die ich sie
besonders informieren möchte
das eine ist wir haben am freitag
darüber uns verständlich und auch eine
entsprechende verordnung erlassen dass
wir im öffentlichen raum also auf den
straßen plätzen und auch in den parks
nur ansammlungen bis zu fünf personen zu
lassen wollen und davon nur ausnahmen in
familiengröße wir haben heute gemeinsam
beschlossen dass wir diese änderung noch
weiter einschränken müssen
wir haben nunmehr vorgesehen dass sich
in diesem öffentlichen raum jemand nur
alleine bewegen darf alleinstehende zum
beispiel ältere mitmenschen die wenn sie
spazieren gehen wollen die hilfe von
jemand anders brauchen sich auch
jemanden zweiten dann sozusagen dazu
nehmen können diese zweite person muss
nicht aus dem familienkreis kommen
sondern es kann auch jemand anders sein
und zum dritten
dass wir auch beschlossen haben dass
diese regelung so auszulegen ist dass
die familien auch hausgemeinschaften
gemeinsam aus können und auch gemeinsam
dann in der öffentlichkeit sich
aufhalten können
frische luft schnappen und alles das was
jeder für sich für wichtig hält also
entscheidend ist einer gegebenfalls plus
einer und häusliche gemeinschaften
das wäre sozusagen ein wesentlicher
punkt auf den haben wir uns
gemeinschaftlich verständigt das gilt
für alle und auf welchen legen wenn das
erreicht ist jetzt mal sekundär
sie wissen dass einige länder ein
ausgehverbot fahrten mit möglichkeit
dieses verbot zu umgehen beziehungsweise
zu erlauben dass man trotzdem raus kann
andere länder wie mir sagen es kommt
nicht darauf an wie sie regeln sind wie
man rauskommt sondern wie viele sich
draußen treffen im ergebnis ist beides
das gleiche und insofern freue ich mich
dass wir zu einer gemeinsamen haltung
gekommen sind haben eine reihe weiterer
beschlüsse gefasst die wir in hessen
alle schon haben zum beispiel die
schließung der gaststätten etc
neu in diesem zusammenhang ist eine
passage in die wir auch vereinbart haben
dass nämlich dienstleistungen die im
bereich der körperpflege stattfinden
eingeschränkt werden das gilt
insbesondere jetzt auch für friseure für
massage salons und ähnliches mehr
die medizinischen notwendigen
behandlungen bleiben alle links möglich
das sind zunächst einmal die dinge die
sich für uns in hessen neu ergeben
alles andere ist bei uns bereits
geregelt wir haben uns darüber hinaus
mit einer ganzen fülle von fragen
beschäftigt die sich mit dem
infektionsschutzgesetz beschäftigen die
sich mit den wirtschaftlichen hilfen
beschäftigen
mit einer fülle von gesetzgebung im
bereich des sozialen schutzes aber auch
der insolvenzordnung des mietrechts
dort herrschte große war einstimmung und
jetzt geht es zunächst einmal darum
sowohl der bund wie die länder brauchen
die parlamentarische zustimmung das
heißt bundestag bundesrat oder wieder in
hessen auch den hessischen landtag
vielleicht so viel zur einstimmung
vielen dank so weit das statement des
ministerpräsidenten gibt es dazu fragen
ich würde erstmal sammeln wer alles
fragen hat und danach ja soweit also die
so weit also die pressekonferenz des
hessischen ministerpräsidenten wir an
dieser stelle verlassen weil wir live
schalten wollen nach stuttgart nach
baden württemberg zum
ministerpräsidenten winfried kretschmann
zweitens die eigene wohnung darf für
alle unbedingt notwendigen tätigkeiten
verlassen werden etwa um zur arbeit oder
zum arzt zu gehen um lebensmittel
einzukaufen
aber auch für sport und bewegung an der
frischen luft sofern das alleine macht
drittens gastronomiebetriebe werden
jetzt also bundesweit geschlossen essen
darf aber weiterhin abgeholt oder
geliefert werden
viertens verstöße gegen die kontakt
beschränkung werden nun wie bereits
zuvor bei uns in baden württemberg in
allen ländern von der polizei den
ordnungsbehörden kontrolliert und
gegebenenfalls auch bestraft fünfter wie
bei uns in baden württemberg wird nun in
der ganzen republik
dienstleistungsbetriebe im bereich der
körperpflege wie etwa friseure
kosmetiker oder tattoo studios
geschlossen
verschärft werden die folgenden beiden
punkte die wir heute noch im
eilverfahren beschließen werden und die
dann ab morgen in baden württemberg
gelten werden
erstens in der öffentlichkeit muss nun
ein mindestabstand von mindestens 1,5
metern eingehalten werden
bitte halten sie sich daran egal ob im
supermarkt beim spazierengehen auf dem
wochenmarkt oder in der straßenbahn
zweitens nunmehr da nur noch zu zweit
draußen unterwegs seien nicht mehr zu
dritt treffen im öffentlichen raum mit
mehr als zwei personen sind also nicht
erlaubt außer für familien
alle diese maßnahmen sollen zunächst
eine geltungsdauer von zwei wochen haben
dann werden wir wieder zusammen
beschließen wie es weitergeht
also wie sie sehen die meisten der
vorgaben gelten in baden württemberg
schon seit samstag wie gesagt alle
kontakte auf das allernotwendigste
reduzieren das öffentliche leben wird
also weitgehend runtergefahren aber wir
machen baden württemberg nicht komplett
dicht wir fangen verbieten also nicht
gewogen zu verlassen ist weiterhin
möglich lebensmittel einzukaufen zur
arbeit zu gehen falls home office
möglich ist ein arzt aufzusuchen oder
frische luft zu schnappen
auch die wissenschaft hat an diesem
wochenende in einem appell von 30
führenden wissenschaftlern diese linie
bestätigt
mir ist sehr bewusst für familien mit
kindern aber auch für alleinstehende es
ist eine enorme psychische
herausforderung sich die meiste zeit in
der wohnung aufzuhalten
die kinder zu betreuen in die neue
fremde situation zu erklären und sie bei
den schularbeiten zu begleiten und
gleichzeitig die eigene arbeit zu
erledigen
meine damen und herren die heutige
einigung mit der kanzlerin und dem
ministerpräsidenten zeit und länder sind
gemeinsam in der lage wirkungsvoll und
abgestimmt zu handeln
dieses abgestimmte verhalten oder das
abgestimmte vorgehen ist wichtig um
vertrauen zu schaffen und wir brauchen
die es um die schwere krise meistern zu
können
es ist ein gegenseitiges vertrauen ihr
vertrauen in uns als politisch
verantwortliche dass wir nach bestem
wissen und gewissen handeln unser
vertrauen in die bürgerinnen und bürger
dass es sich in diesen schweren tagen
vernünftig und verantwortungsvoll
verhalten
die wissenschaft sagt uns allerdings es
wird bis zu 14 tage dauern bis sich der
erfolg dieser mast
namen zeigt bis dahin wird die zahl der
infizierten leider weiter zunehmen
ja also das müssen wir einfach dann auch
durchhalten ja weil das daher kommt dass
die leute sich schon vor diesen
maßnahmen angesteckt haben dann hoffen
wir dass sich die kurve abflacht
aber die fachleute sagen uns das sind
wir uns diesen punkt einig es hängt von
unserem verhalten ab wie schwer das
alles werden wird deshalb bitte ich sie
vermeiden sie kontakte halten sie
abstand und wir halten alle in dieser
schweren zeit zusammen
vielen dank herzlichen dank
in diesem fall für die pressekonferenz
aus baden württemberg wenn wir da einen
überblick wagen und das nämlich als
überleitung zu einem gespräch mit
professor richter
wir haben schon den eindruck das was die
drei ministerpräsidenten die wir jetzt
gehört haben laschet bouffier und
kretschmann gesagt habe das ist im
prinzip deckungsgleich also es scheint
gelungen zu sein alle länder auf eine
linie zu einigen
ja ganz eindeutig und das ist in der tat
mit großer erfolg weil das in der
vergangenheit ja nicht so war ja denken
wir an die schulschließungen wie viel zu
unterschiedlich gestaffelten zeiten an
und darüber hat man sich ja dann auch in
der öffentlichkeit markiert hat gesagt
was soll das jetzt hat man zu dieser
einheitlichen linie gefunden die wird
mit ganz kleinen jahr sondern ein
bisschen anders formuliert von den
einzelnen ministerpräsidenten aber im
grunde ist der maßnahmekatalog in der
tat völlig identisch das ist auch gut so
das ist ein stück eben wenn es wieder
aufgreifen darf unser wort von vorhin
ein funktionsfähiger föderalismus man
hat die einzelstaatliche übereinstimmung
man hat aber eben die kompetenz der
ministerpräsidenten gewahrt und der bund
hat eben an der stelle
die einigung herbeigeführt und so ein
bisschen nach vorangetrieben wir warten
jetzt natürlich noch auf die
pressekonferenz in der bundeskanzlerin
auf die pressekonferenz von angela
merkel
die ist angekündigt für 17.30 also in
sieben minuten soll es soweit sein
ich weiß nicht ob die kollegen kurz
zeigen können auch da liegt uns schon
ein signal vor aus dem bundeskanzleramt
in berlin in sieben minuten live bei uns
professor richter es sind ja es hat sich
das interesse sehr stark konzentriert
auf diese ausgangs begrenzungen oder
beschränkungen
wir legen auch nochmal wert drauf es
gibt keine ausgangssperre in deutschland
es gibt ausgangs begrenzungen das haben
wir uns ausführlich diskutiert jetzt
sind auch noch bundeseinheitlich
offensichtlich weitere maßnahmen
getroffen worden
das schließen aller restaurants und
gaststätten so weit die noch geöffnet
sein konnten teilweise bis 15 bis 18 uhr
und vor allem auch die kontakte berufe
nenne ich das mal friseure masseure die
müssen jetzt ihre tätigkeit einstellen
soweit sie nicht gesundheitlich und
medizinisch geboten sind ja genau also
insofern ist das ein umfassendes
maßnahmenbündel was eben eigentlich
einheitlich den zweck dient eben diese
versammlungen und diese damit dann die
schnelle verbreitung und exponentielle
verbreitung des virus zu unterbinden und
einzuschränken
also insofern alles sinnvoll aber das
hat er ja herr laschet sehr deutlich
angesprochen
das hat natürlich enorme ökonomische
konsequenzen denn für viele bricht in
diesem moment ein komplettes einkommen
weg und das vermutlich über mehrere
wochen das heißt also wir werden da eine
situation haben wo diesen menschen
geholfen werden muss
wobei man sagen kann das ist ja jetzt
auch schon in den maßnahmekatalog den
die ministerpräsidenten heute mit dem
bund erwartet haben drin also man
versucht da eben die langzeitfolgen
irgendwie aufzufangen und über
kurzfristige kredite oder erleichterung
steuererleichterung irgendeine art von
abfederung anzufangen
anzufangen und zu beginnen aber man muss
das natürlich in der tat im
langfristigen wellen sehen das wird eine
ökonomische krise heraufbeschwören die
bewältigt werden muss und gott sei dank
da ist deutschland im vergleich etwa zu
italien in einer relativ komfortablen
lage wird es ja möglich sein über mittel
die der bund zur verfügung hat oder die
abrufen oder reparieren kann über diese
mittel soforthilfe zu leisten aber es
ist in der tat natürlich eine riesige
aufgabe die ganz ganz viele branchen die
selbständigen insbesondere betrifft und
das finde ich schon sehr bemerkenswert
also dass solch eine art von krise
hatten wir jetzt mal von der bankenkrise
abgesehen eigentlich seit dem kriegsende
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert so doch nicht
gesungen die da in deutschland
mobilisiert werden sollen zunächst mal
hauptsächlich für kreditpakete da ist
die rede von weit über 100 milliarden
euro vielleicht sogar mehrere hundert
milliarden euro die in die hand genommen
werden sollen
für kurzarbeitergeld das sind dann
gelder die wirklich an die menschen
fließen aber eben auch für kredite an
die selbständigen an die unternehmen und
das ist ja unter umständen der pferdefuß
das sagen viele dieser unternehmen ja
das sind ja nur kredite ich kann mich
doch nicht bis über halskrause
verschuldet
wenn ich nicht weiß wie es weitergeht
lässt sich diese linie also durchhalten
dass der bund im wesentlichen kredite an
die unternehmen gibt oder wird man über
kurz oder lang sagen müssen wir sagen
das sind verlorene zuschüsse die müssen
nicht zurückgezahlt werden
ja also dieses modell und gibt es ja
auch schon dass man eben tatsächlich
zuschüsse gibt zb an freie künstler
freie kunstszene in berlin soll so
behandelt werden also auch dann versucht
man da an dieser stelle schon irgendwie
auch denjenigen zu helfen von denen man
weiß dass sie diese ausfälle diese
einnahmenausfälle nicht unvermittelt
auffangen können sondern dass
irgendetwas getan werden muss was ihnen
wirklich eine hilfe für verloren gehen
das einkommen liefert also insofern
würde sagen das ist die mischung aus
beidem
und das ist natürlich dann nicht zu
leisten wenn es um die ganz ganz großen
geht ja die großen industrieunternehmen
aber um den mittelstand zu retten muss
man glaube ich in der tat nicht
rückzahlbare finanzhilfen ins auge
fassen sonst kann man diese krise gar
nicht bewältigen
ja professor richter wir haben eine
weitere stellungnahme eine weitere
pressekonferenz vorlegen das ist in dem
fall die ministerpräsidentin von
rheinland pfalz malu dreyer
ich danke an allererster stelle den
beschäftigten im gesundheitssystem im
öffentlichen dienst in all den branchen
die das tägliche leben aufrecht erhalten
sowie auch allen bürgern bürgerin für
die das bei allem
verantwortungsbewusstsein und ihre
bereitschaft sich an diese regeln zu
halten sehr groß ist um der verbreitung
des controller wird des corona virus
weiter zu verlangsamen
nun noch ein bisschen was zu
rheinland-pfalz in viele werden jetzt
den eindruck haben vieles machen wir ja
auch schon in rheinland-pfalz
selbstverständlich viele dieser
maßnahmen die jetzt bundesweit so
miteinander besprochen worden sind sind
bereits in rheinland-pfalz umgesetzt was
ändert sich also in den nächsten tagen
hier in rheinland pfalz wir schränken
zum einen den kreis der kontaktpersonen
weiter ein
deswegen ist das verlassen der eigenen
wohnräume und der aufenthalt im
öffentlichen raum nur alleine mit einer
weiteren nicht im haushalt lebenden
personen oder im kreis der angehörigen
des eigenen hausstands gestattet so
wollen wir dafür sorgen dass die
ansteckungsgefahr sinkt und deshalb
haben wir werden wir auch in
rheinland-pfalz dafür sorgen dass
weitere dienstleistungen verboten werden
zum beispiel friseure kosmetikstudios
nagelstudios tattoo studios davon nicht
betroffen sind medizinische
dienstleistungen wie etwa die
medizinische fußpflege optiker oder
hörgeräte akustiker uns ist sehr bewusst
dass die getroffenen maßnahmen
insbesondere die strikte begrenzung von
sozialen kontakten den alltag der bürger
und bürgerinnen
ganz einschneidend verändert aber wir
gehen sehen aktuell die situation in
unserer nachbarregion grund es in
frankreich und auch in italien wie
rasant und wie tödlich die folgen der
korona pandemie sein können
der kontakt verzicht heute kann morgen
leben retten
an dieser stelle ist es mir auch
nochmals wichtig zu betonen dass wir
tatsächlich vielen vielen menschen auch
zu dank verpflichtet sind die uns helfen
dass das in dieser schwierigen situation
in unserer gesellschaft die wichtige
infrastruktur trotzdem funktioniert und
das sind die ärzte und die ärztin dass
sie die pfleger und pflegerinnen die
polizisten und polizistinnen die
feuerwehrleute die rettungskräfte und
diejenigen die zum beispiel in
lebensmittelläden in bahnen oder busse
an den schulen in den notbetreuung unser
leben und am laufen halten
vielen vielen dank dafür sie arbeiten
jetzt schon bis zur erschöpfung das ist
die aufgabe eines jeden in dieser
historischen situation vernunft und
verständnis zu zeigen und es ist unsere
pflicht sie zu unterstützen indem wir
die schutzmaßnahmen einhalten
ich möchte abschließend noch sagen dass
wir uns darüber hinaus ist sehr intensiv
befasst haben mit dem großen
gesetzespaket das nächste woche sowohl
im kabinett als auch im bundestag als
auch im bundesrat verabschiedet werden
ein gesetzespaket was man vom volumen
her so denke ich in der jüngsten
geschichte zumindestens deutschland noch
nicht gesehen hat da geht es um die
unterstützung von krankenhäusern die
jetzt ganz neue wege gehen müssen und
intensivbetten freihalten um wirklich
intensiv patienten behandeln zu können
es geht um das thema
infektionsschutzgesetz und änderungen
dabei es geht um sie an anpassung der
insolvenz rechtsordnung es geht um den
nachtragshaushalt es geht um das
wirtschafts stabilisierungsfonds gesetz
um corona soforthilfe für
kleinstunternehmen und solo
selbstständige und auch um das sozial
schutzpaket die rheinland pfälzische
landesregierung wird sich am dienstag
umfassend mit diesem gesetzespaket
befassen damit wir am mittwoch und am
freitag im bundesrat dann diese pakete
dann auch entsprechend verabschieden
können
soweit also malu dreyer die
ministerpräsidentin von rheinland-pfalz
wir warten noch auf das was die
bundeskanzlerin zu den ergebnissen der
heutigen sitzung zu sagen hat
angekündigt war ihr statement für 17 uhr
30 im moment haben wir 17 uhr 31 und 22
sekunden also leichte verspätung bei der
bundeskanzlerin wir bleiben dran sobald
sich in berlin im bundeskanzlerin was
tut werden wir daraufhin schalten die
zeit in der zwischenzeit kann ich nutzen
um mich weiter zu unterhalten mit
professor emanuel richter
politikwissenschaftler von der rwth in
aachen zugeschaltet in dem fall aus
berlin professor richter lassen sie uns
mal drüber reden wie sich europa in
dieser krise verhält viele menschen
sagen in dieser krise hat europa nicht
gemeinsam gehandelt europa hat in dieser
krise versagt naja europa müsste man da
genau erfassen ob das das eu europa ist
also die europäische union als
institutionen geflecht oder ob das die
europäischen nationalstaaten sind wenn
man mit letzterem anfängt muss man sagen
ja es gab ja auch ganz unterschiedliche
grade von betroffenheiten und die gibt
es ja immer noch das wechselt ja täglich
aber wir wissen italien allen voran
am schlimmsten betroffenen jetzt rückt
spanien nach frankreich
also insofern gibt es da
unterschiedliche grade von betroffenheit
und damit natürlich auch national
unterschiedliche lösungen
das andere ist wie hat die eu reagiert
als institutionengefüge also
insbesondere die europäische kommission
und da muss man sagen da gab es am
anfang etwas knirschen im getriebe das
heißt es hat nicht sehr gut funktioniert
und dann hat man eben auch auf
öffentlichen druck hin schnell reagiert
hat finanzhilfen in aussicht gestellt
und hat interessanterweise natürlich
damit auch vorübergehend ein paar kahn
bereiche europäische integration
aufgegeben
also denken sie an die schließung der
grenzen der schengen raum der ja
eigentlich offene grenzen
sichern soll denken sie an der stelle
die bundeskanzlerin ist eingetroffen
ihre stellungnahme ich habe mich heute
nachmittag ausführlich mit den
regierungschefs und chefinnen der
bundesländer beraten telefonisch wir
alle sind uns des ernstes der situation
bewusst dass corona videos breitet sich
weiter mit besorgniserregender
geschwindigkeit in unserem land aus wir
haben heute darüber gesprochen wie
unsere gegenmittel greifen und an
gegenmitteln haben wir eben noch keinen
impfstoff und keine medikamente sondern
nur erstens die anstrengungen die wir
unternehmen um unser gesundheitssystem
vor allem die krankenhäuser auf den zu
erwartenden weiteren hohen anstieg der
fallzahlen vorzubereiten
und zweitens unser eigenes verhalten
das ist das derzeit wirksamste mittel
das wir haben
das bedeutet das öffentliche leben so
weit herunter zu fahren die es
vertretbar ist
die begegnung der menschen bei denen das
virus weiter gegeben werden könnte
soweit zu reduzieren wie möglich sie
wissen dass sich bund und länder zu
diesem zweck am montag bereits auf
einschneidende maßnahmen geeinigt hatten
und wir hatten vereinbart dass wir an
diesem wochenende eine zwischenbilanz
ziehen werden heute am sonntag stellen
wir überall in deutschland fest unsere
städte unser verkehr
unser wirtschaftliches und privates
leben sehen vollkommen anders aus als
noch vor einer woche
die überwältigende mehrheit der menschen
hat verstanden dass es jetzt auf jeden
und jede ankommt dass jeder und jede
sein und ihren teil dazu beitragen kann
aber auch muss das virus aufzuhalten
bevor ich ihnen gleich im einzelnen die
erweiterten leitlinien erläutere auf die
sich bund und länder heute geeinigt
haben ist es mir wichtig
mich direkt an all diejenigen zu wenden
die sich jetzt an die notwendigen
verhaltensregeln halten
ich danke ihnen dafür ich weiß dass es
verzicht und opfer bedeutet
wirtschaftlich wie menschlich wenn
geschäfte schließen müssen wenn man
nicht mehr so einfach unter leute gehen
kann und was noch viel schmerzhafter ist
nicht mehr so einfach die großeltern
besuchen darf freunde treffen darf wir
alle müssen darauf eine zeit lang
verzichten
dass sich so viele an diese
verhaltensregeln halten das berührt mich
sehr so zeigen wir fürsorge für ältere
und vor erkrankte menschen denen würde
das virus am gefährlichsten
kurz gesagt so retten wir leben
ich habe ihnen bereits am mittwoch
gesagt so dynamisch die ausbreitung des
virus ist so flexibel müssen wir unsere
maßnahmen auch immer wieder angehen wir
müssen sozusagen in der lage lärm von
den experten die der epidemie immer neue
erkenntnisse abgewinnen und von der
beobachtung der wirklichkeit welche
maßnahmen werden reibungslos umgesetzt
und wo hakt es noch
und warum in diesem sinne haben sich die
bundesregierung und die bundesländer
heute verständigt die leitlinien für das
verhalten und für die bewegungsfreiheit
und mobilität an die sich alle zu halten
haben noch einmal zu erweitern
so reduzieren wir weiter konsequent
öffentliches leben und die sozialen
kontakte und wir sorgen dafür dass in
ganz deutschland im grundsatz die
gleichen regeln gelten
viele bürger haben uns ja deutlich
wissen lassen dass sie sich diese
klarheit auch im föderalen staat
wünschen
jeder soll wissen alle staatlichen
ebenen in deutschland der bund die
länder und die kommunen arbeiten an
einem großen ja lebenswichtigen ziel
zeit zu gewinnen im kampf gegen das
virus
und deshalb haben wir uns auf folgende
leitlinien
gehen heute ergänzende leitlinien
verständigt die ich ihnen vortragen
möchte erstens die bürgerinnen und
bürger werden angehalten die kontakte zu
anderen menschen außerhalb der
angehörigen des eigenen hausstandes auf
ein absolut nötiges minimum zu
reduzieren
zweitens in der öffentlichkeit ist wo
immer möglich zu anderen als den unter
eben genannten personen ein
mindestabstand von mindestens 1,5 meter
besser noch zwei meter einzuhalten
drittens der aufenthalt im öffentlichen
raum ist nur alleine mit einer weiteren
noch im haushalt lebenden personen also
einer weiteren im haushalt lebenden
personen oder im kreis der angehörigen
des eigenen hausstands gestattet
viertens der weg zur arbeit zur
notbetreuung einkäufe arztbesuche
teilnahme an sitzungen erforderlichen
terminen und prüfungen hilfe für andere
individueller sport und bewegung an der
frischen luft sowie andere notwendige
tätigkeiten bleiben selbstverständlich
weiter möglich fünftens gruppe feiernder
menschen auf öffentlichen plätzen in
wohnungen sowie privaten einrichtungen
sind angesichts der ernsten lage unserem
land inakzeptabel
verstöße gegen die kontakt
beschränkungen sollen von
ordnungsbehörden und der polizei
überwacht und bei zuwiderhandlungen
sanktioniert werden sechstens
gastronomiebetriebe werden geschlossen
davon ausgenommen ist die lieferung und
abholung mitnahme fähiger speisen für
den verzehr zu hause siemens dies
dienstleistungsbetriebe im bereich der
körperpflege wie friseure
kosmetikstudios massagepraxen tattoo
studios und ähnliche betriebe werden
geschlossen weil sie in diesem bereich
eine körperliche nähe haben die ja
unabdingbar für die berufsausübung ist
und deshalb nicht zu den leitlinien die
wir uns gegeben haben passen
medizinisch notwendige behandlungen
bleiben weiter möglich achtens in allen
betrieben und insbesondere solche mit
publikumsverkehr ist es wichtig die
hygienevorschriften einzuhalten und
wirksame schutzmaßnahmen für mitarbeiter
und besucher umzusetzen und neunter
diese maßnahmen sollen eine
geltungsdauer von mindestens zwei wochen
haben
damit weiß jeder wo immer er oder sie
lebt genau woran er ist
jeder soll seine bewegungen und sein
leben für die nächsten wochen nach
diesen klaren vorgaben organisieren
niemand von uns die wir in der
demokratie politische verantwortung
tragen hat sich gewünscht je mit solchen
regelungen vor die bürger treten zu
müssen
ich sage aber auch dies sind nicht
einfach irgendwelche empfehlungen des
staates es sind regeln die in unserer
aller interesse einzuhalten sind
die ordnungskräfte werden das überprüfen
und wo sie verstöße feststellen wird es
folgen haben und strafen geben
ich wiederhole daher meinen dringlichen
appell an sie alle gerade auch an die
wenigen die sich mit der einhaltung der
regeln in den letzten tagen noch schwer
getan haben bitte ziehen sie alle mit
tun sie jetzt das was richtig ist für
unser land zeigen sie vernunft und herz
unzählige mitbürger arbeiten im
gesundheitssystem oder halten unsere
tägliche versorgung aufrecht wir sollten
ihnen dafür immer danken
vor allem aber schulden wir ihnen dass
wir dem virus so wenig möglichkeit geben
sich auszubreiten wie wir das irgendwie
können
es ist an diesem tag eine große
ermutigung zu sehen dass millionen und
abermillionen von menschen diesen
verzicht aus gemein sind und fürsorge
für die gefährdeten auch ganz praktisch
leisten
ich bin überzeugt
dieser gemeinsinn dieses getreten
füreinander ein wird uns alle gemeinsam
durch diese schwere zeit tragen
herzlichen dank frau bundeskanzlerin als
sie die maßnahmen vorgelesen haben haben
sie gesagt
der aufenthalt im öffentlichen raum ist
nur alleine mit einer weiteren im
haushalt lebenden personen oder im kreis
der angehörigen des eigenen haushalts
gestattet ist es muss doch heißen damit
ein fehler
das habe ich dann einen fehler gemacht
da lese ich gleich noch mal vor damit
was alles richtig haben
der aufenthalt im öffentlichen raum ist
nur alleine mit einer weiteren nicht im
haushalt lebenden person oder im kreis
der angehörigen des eigenen hausstands
gestattet dann haben wir es noch mal
ganz perfekt danke ich habe aber
trotzdem noch eine frage und zwar gab es
ja vorschläge die sanktionen kann ganz
konkret dort reinzuschreiben etwa 25.000
euro an strahlt strafandrohungen wenn
nicht aus dem kreis der
ministerpräsidenten kamen solche
vorschläge wenn nicht dieses
versammlungsverbot oder ein
kontaktverbot so zusagen eingehalten
wird oder auch der erweiterung mit
freiheitsstrafen warum ist das nicht
drin und es soll ja eine
auseinandersetzung gegeben haben
zwischen den ministerpräsidenten söder
und laschet liegen die nerven blank
also es hat eine wie immer lebendige
diskussion gegeben das ist aber auch
ganz normal von strafhöhen oder
ordnungsgeldern ist heute nicht
gesprochen worden in welcher höhe das
hat überhaupt gar keine rolle gespielt
und ansonsten muss ich ihnen sagen es
ist doch wichtig dass wir uns darauf
geeinigt haben dass wir die kontakte
reduzieren dass wir trotzdem den
menschen erlauben wollen das haus zu
verlassen dass sie rausgehen können für
die notwendigen tätigkeiten aber eben
auch um frische luft zu schöpfen das
kann man in der familie machen mit denen
die im hausstand leben und eben auch
wenn man alleine lebt mit einer zweiten
person zusammen das wird manchmal so
geschrieben dass es sozusagen im
öffentlichen raum nur zwei menschen
zusammen sein können
außer es handelt sich um menschen die in
einem haus stand wohl und ich glaube das
ist eine gute und richtige regelung
darauf haben sich alle geeinigt pro
bundeskanzlerin zwei fragen das eine
haben sie sich mit dem
ministerpräsidenten auch über die reform
des infektionsschutzgesetzes geeinigt da
geht es darum ob der bund in
krisenzeiten wie der jetzigen mehr
kompetenzen erhält da müssen ja die
bundesländer zustimmen
und zweitens haben sie sich auch über
wirtschaftliche hilfsmaßnahmen
verständigt da gibt es ja die
zusatzforderung dass man in einer
haftungs obergrenze von 100 prozent bei
krediten übernimmt gibt es verständnis
wir haben morgen um 11 uhr eine
kabinettssitzung danach werden der
bundesfinanzminister und ich ihnen hier
an dieser stelle auch zu einem statement
zur verfügung stehen die gesetze werden
erläutert werden wir sind noch voll im
verarbeitungsprozess und deshalb kann
ich zur ausgestaltung dieser gesetze
heute nichts sagen
es wird es wird kommen und die details
werden gerade noch abgestimmt es muss
sich keiner sorgen machen und die
überschriften heute in manchen zeitungen
waren auch vollkommen übertrieben
also da werden wir eine gute einigung
finden auch mit den bundesländern wir
haben ja eine bundesrats sondersitzung
am freitag
und wir wollen natürlich dass in dieser
bundesrats sondersitzung auch die
gesetze beschlossen werden es wäre ja
nicht besonders logisch wenn wir im
bundestag etwas verabschieden was
anschließend vom bundesrat nicht
mitgetragen wird der titel von der bild
zeitung herr laschet hat heute den
begriff von kontaktverbot geprägt was
halten sie von dem begriff und wie
werden sie vielleicht können sie mal
erläutern dass wir sich selber ganz
persönlich umsätzen in der arbeit und in
dem alltag und eine zweite frage wie
erklären sie die und den bürgern dass
sie trotzdem dann entdecken einen
flickenteppich haben weil wir haben
jetzt so ein grundgerüst das war auch
dass man sich gerade mal so einigen
konnte es gab ja streit dass die
bundesländer die gehen weit deutlich
deutlich weiter wir haben bayern wir
haben sachsen und wir haben maßnahmen in
den kommunen wie zum beispiel freiburg
die deutlich weiter gehen wie erklären
sie dass die noten also wir haben uns
heute darauf geeinigt dass wir die
kontakte reduzieren
es ist ja so dass jeder noch kontakte
haben wird entweder mit den menschen mit
denen er im haushalt lebt oder man kann
einen mit nach draußen nehmen und man
wird auch andere kontakte haben zum
beispiel über das telefonieren oder
skaten also kontakte sind ja nicht immer
nur dass man sich gegenüber steht
zweitens glaube ich dass ein grundgerüst
das jetzt sehr sehr ähnlich ist zwischen
den einzelnen bundesländern und das ja
viele bundesländer auch noch gar nicht
alles aus formuliert hatten aber alle
ministerpräsidenten haben heute genau
diesen leitlinien zugestimmt davon sind
nicht alle fallkonstellationen erfasst
manche verordnung wird noch sehr viel
spezifischer sein aber dieses paar male
mitgetragen und ich glaube das sind ja
auch die grund botschaften an die
menschen und jetzt nochmal zu der frage
wie ist die auseinandersetzung wurde
geredet ist gibt natürlich diskussionen
das ist aber bei jeder mp konferenz so
wenn wir hier hinter ihnen in dem raum
sitzen dann geht das auch durchaus zur
sache dass es ja auch vernünftig ich
meine wir sind leben in einer echt
schwierigen situation
wir beschränken viele freiheiten die für
uns ganz selbstverständlich sind und
dass da unterschiedliche ideen auch
eingebracht werden das ist finde ich
normal
schauen sie doch mal wie sie hier sitzen
gucken sie mal wie wir unsere
kabinettssitzung machen
ich habe alle nahezu alle termine
abgesagt in denen menschen hierher
kommen ins kanzleramt oder in denen ich
zu menschen fahren würde also mein leben
hat sie auch grundsätzlich verändert und
besteht im wesentlichen aus telefon- und
videokonferenzen
der europäische rat findet die stadt es
finden keine reise statt ich habe fahren
nirgendwo in deutschland hin wenn ich
besuche machen würde sonst als termine
also dass alles im feld frau
bundeskanzlerin vor gut einer woche gab
es ja schon mal den versuch dass die
länder und der bund sich einigen auf
eine einheitliche situation kurz danach
ist der bayerische ministerpräsident
wieder mit dem ruf nach verschärfungen
vorgeprescht nehmen sie ihm das
eigentlich übel und glauben sie dass das
bewusstsein vorherrscht dass das jetzt
nicht mehr zu diesen alleingängen kommt
sollen sie die lage ist sehr sehr
unterschiedlich wenn sie sich allein mal
die betroffenheit der einzelnen
bundesländer anschauen dann ist das
unterschiedlich und wir haben die
bundesländer bayern baden württemberg
und saarland insbesondere in gewisser
weise auch rheinland-pfalz aber die drei
die ich zuerst genannt habe ganz
besonders in denen grenznähe da ist wo
nachbarländer auch bestimmte maßnahmen
ergriffen haben und die sind natürlich
dann nochmal sensibler als dann auch
immer gleich zur verwerfung in den
pendlerverkehr und so weit kommen kann
und insofern
geht es darum dass wir am montag schon
gesagt haben wir gucken uns das mal
anhalten sich die menschen dran ich habe
das ja auch am mittwoch als aufruf
gestartet
ich freue mich heute dass so viele dass
auch freiwillig machen aber es gab eben
auch situationen deshalb haben fast alle
bundesländer auch schon über das
wochenende die restaurants geschlossen
und die cafés wo wir gesehen haben dass
das mit den kontakt reduzierungen mit
den abstandsregelungen vor allen dingen
nicht so gut eingehalten wird ich will
vielleicht noch mal sagen es ist das
aller aller wichtigste dass die
abstandsregeln eingehalten werden
die frage wenn ich draußen bin und
draußen rumlaufen ist eben ganz ganz
wichtig abstandsregel denn mit einem
bestimmten abstand reduziert sich das
infektionsrisiko nahezu auf null
ob sie also einen halben meter
voneinander entfernt stehen oder 1,5
meter macht einen riesenunterschied auch
wenn man das vielleicht aus seinem
bisherigen leben so noch nicht gesehen
hatte ich bedanke mich soweit also die
bundeskanzlerin in ihrer pressekonferenz
zu dem was die bundeskanzlerin mit den
16 ministerpräsidenten heute nachmittag
geschlossen hat nach wie vor bin ich
verbunden mit professor emanuel richter
politikwissenschaftler von der
universität aachen professor richter wie
beurteilen sie das was die kanzlerin da
eben gesagt hat naja es deckt sich ja an
vielen stellen wörtlich mit dem was die
ministerpräsidenten verkündet haben also
das ist eben das einheitliche vorgehen
ich würde aber gleichzeitig sagen sie
ist ja an manchen stellen auch in ihren
formulierungen darüber hinaus gegangen
und es war erneut sehr staatstragend
also erneut im sinne der rede die sie
vor ein paar tagen gehalten hat der
ansprache an die nation gewissermaßen
das insofern macht sie da glaube ich
ihren job sehr gut sie wendet sich sehr
eindringlich an das volk
sie spricht für ihre verhältnisse
ungewöhnlich emotional und trotzdem aber
so vernunft betont und ruhig und mit dem
aufruf an gelassenheit dass man
irgendwie in der bevölkerung vielleicht
das gefühl haben kann also unsere
polizei
für exekutiv spitze im bund ist imstande
diese notsituation irgendwie zu meistern
zu bewältigen und die richtigen
maßnahmen und die richtigen also die
richtigen maßnahmen zu ergreifen und die
richtigen worte zu finden also insofern
hat mir das gut gefallen
sie hat sich ja auch bedankt bei den
menschen die sich an die regeln halten
und vor allem bei denen die da in den
gesundheitsberufen an vorderster front
kämpfen
aber sie hat etwas nicht gemacht wofür
sie in der flüchtlingskrise häufig
gescholten wurde ein satz wie wir
schaffen das der war nicht dabei aus
gutem grund denke ich ja genau also
diese formulierung ist wenn man so will
verdorben die kann man natürlich und sie
insbesondere nicht mehr verwenden ohne
dass es wieder ein aufschrei im volk
gibt aber letztendlich ist das ja doch
irgendwie in der sache durchaus
ähnliches ist eine nationale und
natürlich mittlerweile auch ins globale
also europäische globale herausforderung
die bewältigt werden muss und
gleichzeitig signalisiert sie ja dass
der bund und die länder im einvernehmen
maßnahmen ergreifen die darauf
hinauslaufen sollen das zu schaffen
zwar mit einer reihe von todesopfern mit
einer reihe von ökonomischen
verwerfungen die uns noch lange
beschäftigen werden aber die politik und
die exekutive ist er an der stelle dazu
da irgendwie eine art von bewältigung
vorzugeben und dem volk und der
bevölkerung deutlich zu machen
wir wissen was auf uns zukommt wir
wissen was zu tun ist und wir wissen wie
wir koordiniert handeln können und diese
botschaft hat sie glaube ich gut
rübergebracht und das ist ja in der tat
was was die politik im moment leisten
kann mehr kann sie auch nicht denn das
ist in der tat eine herausforderung die
man nicht nur mit politischen maßnahmen
bewältigen kann sondern wo man eben
schauen muss dass man vor allen dingen
die art der gesundheitlichen
beeinträchtigungen auf fängt also damit
sind die alle gesundheitsinstitutionen
mehr gefordert als jetzt wie die großen
politischen worte oder die an